[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et à toutes bienvenue à
cette direction conférence avant de
parler de perception et de réalité
j'aimerais que tous façons pardon petit
exercice super simple super rapide afin
de se sentir un petit peu mieux que l'on
se sent actuellement je vais vous
inviter à gentiment fermer vos yeux s'il
vous plaît
je vais d'abord vous donner la totalité
et après je vous donnerai la consigne en
temps réel pour que nous ayons tous le
même compte voici ce que nous allons
faire nous allons inspirer par notre nez
et c'est le ventrer uniquement le ventre
qui va gonfler
je vais retenir ensuite ma respiration
pendant trois secondes quand je vais
arriver au sommet de mon inspiration et
à la fin de ces trois secondes je vais
expirer de nouveau par mon nez
et mon ventre va dégonfler légèrement je
donne le décompte et on va commencer
avec la première respiration 3 2 1 c'est
parti j'inspire par mon nez mon ventre
gonfle uniquement le ventre uniquement
le ventre grande inspiration
je retiendrai respiration pendant trois
secondes 1 2 3
j'expire de nouveau par mon nez mon
ventre des gants super je vois plein
d'épaules qui se baisse ça fait du bien
de pas être stresser n'est-ce pas
j'inspire de nouveau par mon mais mon
ventre gonfle encore encore
je retiens ma respiration pendant trois
secondes
1 3
e et dernier respiration j'inspire on
est
je retiens ma respiration pendant trois
secondes
1 2 3 et j'expire par mon nez et on
rentre des mots
super nous sommes de retour
je pense que
c'est importantes dans la vie pour
qu'elle soit pleinement épanouie et
beaucoup plus douce et facile c'est de
passer un petit peu de temps à étudier
ce que les mots veulent dire pas
nécessairement avoir un vocabulaire
énormément étoffé mais peut-être se dire
je me pose un moment je me dis je tiens
je vais pouvoir dans le dictionnaire ce
que le mot par exemple perception veut
dire et je lis les définitions je lis
les origines du mot etc
et j'aimerais pour que nous comprenions
davantage le principe de perception et
l'idée ça serait de définir déjà ces
deux mots avant même de commencer à
donner de la nouvelle information
n'est-ce pas commençons par le début
qu'est-ce que le mauvais dire donc j'ai
emmené avec moi ces deux définitions
commençons s'il vous plaît par
perception perception l'origine du mot
et la suivante du latin perception
lui-même issu du latin perceptum
la Scipio qui signifie saisir percevoir
j'ai apporté avec moi deux définitions à
l'évidence il y en a beaucoup plus mais
ça va vraiment être sur celle-ci que
nous allons focaliser dans cette
présentation première définition action
de percevoir par les organes des sens
par exemple la perception des couleurs
deuxième exemple la perception par le
toucher
deuxième définition et retenez bien
celle-ci
ID compréhension plus ou moins nette de
quelque chose et pour les plus attentifs
attentifs d'entre vous vous avez vu que
j'ai mis le mot chose en gras
premier exemple avoir une perception
confuse de la situation deuxième exemple
j'ai une faible perception du problème
comme vous pouvez le voir c'est
définition viennent du Larousse en ligne
vous pourrez les retrouver là-bas si
vous le souhaitez
passons maintenant s'il vous plaît à la
définition de réalité n'oubliez pas la
deuxième définition de perception
réalité origine du mot du latin médiéval
réalité un classique réaliste de race
qui signifie chose
souvenez-vous la deuxième définition du
mot perception
première définition du mot réalité
caractère de ce qui est réel de ce qui
existe effectivement premier exemple
douter de la réalité d'un fait deuxième
exemple c'est une réalité incontestable
deuxième définition ce qui est réel ce
qui existe en fait par opposition à ce
qui est imaginé rêvé ou fictif
premier exemple facile celui-ci je vous
l'accorde la réalité dépasse la fiction
deuxième exemple le rêve et la réalité
sont de choses différentes
vous avez vu que l'origine de réalité
vient de reste qui veut dire chose
substituons le mot chose à la définition
de perception s'il vous plaît ça donne
ceci idées compréhensions plus ou moins
nettes de la
question pour vous la suivante
y a-t-il autant de perceptions qu'il y a
de réalité dans ce monde
je pourrais juste arrêter la
présentation ici tout est dit dans les
mots mais bien sûr continuons
maintenant que c'est deux mots sont
mieux compris je l'espère
qu'est-ce qui se passe
lorsque plusieurs personnes sont
spectateur d'une seule et même situation
mais que tout le monde en a une
perception ou une compréhension
différente
qu'est-ce qui se passe vraiment ici
il y a un facteur qui explique cela
ce sont les filtres internes les filtres
internes les filtres internes qui font
nous voyons et ce que nous entendons les
mélanges et on donne une compréhension
qui est la nôtre
caisse déjà arrivé ou peut-être vous
étiez dans un repas d'affaires entre
membres de la famille entre amis où il y
a quelqu'un qui raconte une histoire de
façon vraiment tout à fait brillante
avec plein de détails c'est hilarant
attention
et quand la personne termine de raconter
l'histoire dans ma tête vous dites c'est
absolument pas ça qui s'est passé je le
sais à qui c'est déjà arrivé ça en
levant la main
ok super par contre vous devriez tous et
toutes lever la main sinon si vous
n'avez pas compris la question ici ok
non mais ce que je vous ai vu dans le
fond là-bas
et la question c'est la suivante comment
ça se fait que mes camarades
oui un point de vue différent du mien
et bien écoutez bien celle-ci
les filtres internes fonctionnent de la
manière suivante
ils sont basés sur premièrement nos
croyances et deuxièmement nous
expériences passées nos croyances et nos
expériences passées
si par exemple je demandais à salya de
revenir sur le devant parmi nous et de
nous poser une question suivante par
exemple comment passons-nous du dorsal
ostéatique par exemple admettons que ce
serait la question qu'elle nous poserait
elle a donné une seule explication de
comment réaliser ce signe n'est-ce pas
incontestablement si on devait
l'expliquer à notre tour tout le monde
utilisera des mots différents et tout le
monde expliquerait d'une façon
pourquoi parce que nous avons tout des
filtres internes différents
et c'est bon ou mauvais simplement ce
que nous nous avons perçu mais c'est
parce que Salia a dit
j'aimerais continuer en parlant des
points de vue
la première chose à savoir des points de
vue c'est que à l'évidence toujours
différent
donc tous au courant de ça pas de
problème mais quand un point de vue est
engagé
c'est que j'ai envie de vous proposer
c'est de toujours prendre
un pas de recul et de se dire qu'est-ce
que les personnes
pourraient ou ont perçu à leur tour
sur cette situation donnée
de faire ça
se poser cette question va vous donner
un avantage majeur dans vos relations
garanties
vous allez voir plus de possibilités
vous allez voir plus grand et vous allez
commencer à voir ce que les autres ne
voient pas
j'ai apporté avec moi
deux images on va commencer par la
première et nous allons faire une
expérience avec ces deux images et nous
allons un petit peu en discuter mais
juste avant de faire ça j'aimerais vous
narrer une histoire très rapide qui nous
est arrivé avec les personnes avec qui
je travaille vous l'avez vu dans le
titre dans notre wewashi Kong je ne vais
pas en parler si mais peut-être après si
vous souhaitez en parler ce sera avec
grand plaisir
je me souviens une fois de professeur
nous a dit on s'entraînait entre membres
de l'équipe ici il y avait pas encore
les participants et participantes et
nous a dit mettez-vous en cercle et
avant même de commencer cet exercice je
veux que chacun et chacune d'entre vous
me dites exactement ce que vous faites
pour réaliser cet exercice donnez-moi la
recette qui fait que ça marche il s'est
passé deux phénomènes très intéressants
ici
le premier c'est que tout le monde est
donné des points
qui étaient similaires les uns par
rapport aux autres et deuxième chose
point beaucoup plus intéressant c'est
surtout ce qu'on vient de dire
c'est que chacun et chacune d'entre nous
avions légèrement ajouté nos propres
épices à la recette qui fait que ça
marche
alors à l'évidence mon professeur nous a
toujours donné qu'une seule façon de
bien réaliser cet exercice mais pourtant
tout le monde avait légèrement modifié
la recette qui nous avait donné
ça n'est pas ça n'a pas tourné en à la
défaveur des participants et
participants puisque nous nous
entraînons avant à savoir enseigner cet
exercice mais qu'est-ce qui aurait pu se
passer ici mettons
façon l'exercice
qu'est-ce qui se serait passé selon vous
c'est super simple les amis les gens
n'auraient pas eu la bonne information
ils auraient eu une information diluée
qui ne vient pas de la source une
information qui n'est pas pure et donc
le résultat aurait été beaucoup moins
spectaculaire
et ça ça arrive souvent avec
l'information aujourd'hui elle est
diluée diluée diluer du lait parce que
tout le monde rajoute son épice à
l'intérieur mais d'être conscient de
comment fonctionne les filtres internes
va vous permettre de contrecarrer
quasiment la totalité de ces légères
incompréhensions
qui a envie que je partage un secret
ultra simple maintenant en levant la
main sur comment compter les filtres
internes avec les gens
super
écoutez un selfie les amis
il s'agit de poser des questions
ce qui va faire c'est tout
quand quelqu'un dit quelque chose si
vous n'êtes pas sûr à 100%
posez la question et demandez-lui
excuse-moi Thomas quand tu as dit ceci
est-ce que c'est bien ça que tu voulais
dire et là Thomas pourrait dire oui
c'est parfait c'est ça on y va on fonce
ou à l'inverse il voudrait dire ah non
c'est carrément vas-y c'est ça que j'ai
dit
merci on va gagner beaucoup de temps
si vous êtes sur même à 99 %. c'est
comme la question de faire ça va tout
changer dans vos relations je vous le
garantis
posez à vos enfants au conjoint conjoint
à vos mère vos pères et quand tu as dit
ceci moi j'ai compris ça mais est-ce que
c'était vraiment
peux-tu me dire
ça va vous prendre 20 secondes maximum
et vous allez obtenir des résultats
merveilleux s'il vous plaît
nous allons passer avec la petite
expérience des images elle va apparaître
seulement pendant une seconde et ensuite
je vais vous poser des questions
rapidement sur celle-ci et vous donner
un petit peu d'informations à ce sujet
3 2 1 apparition
en levant la main qui a vu une jeune
dame
super en levant la main qui avait une
dame âgée
je vais vous donner davantage
d'informations sur
comment fonctionne le traitement de la
perception il y a deux formes de
traitement premier traitement c'est le
traitement ascendant c'est uniquement
basé sur vos 5 sens
deuxième traitement beaucoup plus
intéressant c'est le traitement
descendant
qui est directement relié aux illusions
d'optique
et sur quoi se base le traitement
descendant si vous avez suivi depuis le
début vous avez déjà la réponse
sur nos croyances
et sur nos expériences passées donc ma
question pour vous est la suivante y
a-t-il autant de perceptions
qu'il y a de réalité
cette image est assurément extrêmement
connue je pense que pour la plupart
d'entre vous vous l'avez reconnu et là
ce ne connaissons pas l'illustrateur
mais elle s'appelle ma femme et ma
belle-mère donc pour ceux qui n'ont pas
vu la jeune dame et la dame âgée je veux
vous le montrer maintenant la dame jeune
vous avez le Cilici
le nez ici avec la bouche le menton et
le cou pour la dame âgée vous avez le
gros nez ici avec la petite verrue ici
l'œil ici
le bout du nez ici l'arrêt du nez ici la
bouche
une expérience a été faite avec cette
image qui nous démon que les personnes
qui sont d'un âge plus avancé seront
beaucoup plus propices à voir la dame
âgée et à l'inverse pour les personnes
qui sont plus jeunes ils auront beaucoup
plus propices à voir la dame jaune à
bonne entendeur
prochaine image
3 2 1 c'est parti
ok en levant la main qui a vu un canard
OK
enlevant la main qui a vu à lapin
d'accord
excellent
cette image nous vient du psychologue
Joseph jasselot qui s'intitule je vais
vous montrer le lapin
le lapin les oreilles sont ici vous avez
l'oeil ici vous avez le bout du nez avec
la bouche ici et pour le canard à
l'évidence vous avez le bec ici vous
avez le ici et l'arrière de la tête ici
j'ai apporté avec moi la traduction
française exacte
des études de Monsieur jasmelot quant à
cette image donc c'est paru dans son
livre qui s'appelle facts and fable in
psychology je vais vous lire exactement
ce qu'il a dit au sujet de la perception
il est bon au moins occasionnellement de
se rappeler que nous conceptions de la
science et de la vérité de la nature de
la logique et de l'évidence ne sont pas
aussi universelles que nous le supposons
sans réfléchir ou comme nous l'espérons
donc ce qu'il faut comprendre ici c'est
que pour lui la vision n'est pas que la
résultante de l'activité des yeux le
cerveau peut aussi percevoir ce qu'il
décide il conclut en disant ceci
le traitement mental d'une image est au
centre de l'interprétation du monde
le traitement mental d'une image centre
de l'interprétation du monde
ma question pour vous et y a-t-il autant
de perception
qu'il y a de réalité
tout ça pour dire les amis ce qu'ils
font conclure ici c'est que
comprendre que tout le monde a des
filtres internes différents que tout le
monde a une perception différente et
donc une réalité différente
à plusieurs avantages déjà premièrement
nous allons beaucoup moins juger les
gens parce que nous allons comprendre
qu'ils ont tous des croyances et des
expériences de vie différentes qui sont
pas les nôtres et c'est super c'est OK
avec ça
deuxièmement cette scène intéressante
nous allons beaucoup moins être vexé
mais en colère infligé atterré déçu
triste et je pourrais continuer encore
et encore quand quelqu'un veut dire
quelque chose parce que c'est sa
perception c'est pas la nôtre nous
n'avons pas à prendre les émotions
négatives de cette personne parce que
c'est ce que lui il a compris de cette
situation ce qu'il a vécu ce qu'il a vu
c'est pas nous tout va bien
troisième avantage majeur
nous allons voir une vie plus riche plus
douce plus épanouie plus stimulante et
plus excitante pourquoi parce que de
comprendre ça nos relations
on se transformait pour le meilleur
retenez bien ceci s'il vous plaît les
amis si vous ne partez qu'avec une seule
chose c'est ceci le monde ne se limite
pas à ce que nous percevons
individuellement
n'est-ce pas
merci pour votre écoute et passons la
suite du programme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]